today on the matt wall show schools
across the country are shutting down
again many of them still have never
opened in the first place
it's clear that the people running the
education system to include the teachers
unions especially in fact
don't really care that much about
education so where does that leave us
also five headlines including a
bombshell study
which seems to vindicate the
anti-massacres we were told they're
anti-science maybe not so much plus
japan
starts using robots to enforce social
distancing and our daily cancellation
and much more all in the way but first
uh a word from
one of our american sponsors my pillow
you know
uh it's there's nothing more important
than getting a good
good night's sleep it's not it doesn't
just help your sanity but also
you for your for your health you need to
in order to be a healthy person you need
to be able to sleep at night i know for
me
you know um i i always felt like
uh i was sort of an insomniac i had a
lot of trouble sleeping
what i realized is that i just have very
specific sleep needs i need certain
things in order to sleep well
if i have those needs met uh so i'm kind
of like a diva when it comes to sleep if
i had the knees met then i could sleep i
sleep like a baby
and in fact i'll sleep through the baby
crying which my wife is not a big fan of
but my pillow i can blame my pillow for
that because ever since i started using
my pillow
uh i sleep great mike lindell is the
inventor of my pillow
and his stuff is just great everything
about it their pillows won't go flat the
pillows are always you know most pillows
you get
after a while of using them uh they're
all flat you kind of flimsy you need to
buy new ones that doesn't happen with my
pillow
you can wash and dry them as many times
as you want and they maintain their
shape
and best of all you know they're made in
the usa so that's jobs in the usa that's
products being made in the usa
if you don't have my pillow or know
someone who doesn't who doesn't now's
the time because for a limited time mike
is offering his premium my pillows
uh yes the ones that started it all for
his lowest price ever you can get a
queen size premium my pillow regularly
69.98 for only 29.98 that's
40 in savings and kings are only five
dollars more
so this is this is you know you're not
gonna get a deal like this very often
folks now is the time to buy not only
are you only getting are you getting the
lowest price ever
but they are the best christmas gift
ever also so we got christmas around the
corner
and um you don't want to break the bank
on christmas so now is the time to get
this gift
for someone that you uh you care about
this is a this is a gift that anyone
will love
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the
giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets or you could
call
800 800-651-1148 and use
promo code daily wire
well a parent of a child in the seattle
public school system tweeted that
her daughter's language arts class was
canceled on monday because the teacher
was quote living in the forest
and unable to find an adequate internet
connection to conduct the lesson
remotely
now as as funding as funny as the living
in the forest excuse to get out of work
may seem
and as much as i lament not using the
same excuse when i was working remotely
for
the daily wire before coming to
nashville this speaks to a reality
that's actually not very funny at all
that is
that the matter of educating children
has become an afterthought
a sideshow something that a teacher can
do while living in the forest
unless the internet goes out in which
case well i guess the kids don't need to
hear about language arts that day
schools across the country of course
shut down in mass
last year in response to the coronavirus
this in spite of the fact that we knew
very early on in fact it was
one of the first data points we all knew
reliably
that children are not likely carriers
contractors or spreaders of the disease
there was never any solid data-driven
reason to shut down the schools
there especially isn't one now as we
have
months of evidence showing that schools
are among the least
dangerous places the least infectious
places
there's also plenty of evidence that the
alternative
to open schools uh remote learning
is a disaster the other the other
alternative homeschooling
is preferable to both but the fact is
that millions upon millions of children
have been stuck with remote learning for
months now
and there's little reason to think that
they're benefiting
at all from it and now just as schools
had started to open up again for
in-person learning
many are reverting back to the charade
of online learning instead just
yesterday new york mayor
bill de blasio announced that new york
schools would be shutting down once
again
they joined schools in pittsburgh
michigan many other places
in closing down again after sort of
reopening
here's de blasio making the announcement
and pay attention to the reason that he
gives listen to this
unfortunately as of today on our
seven-day rolling average for
coronavirus positivity new york city has
hit exactly 3.0 percent
and as a result we do need to close our
schools
for the coming days no one is
happy about this decision we all in fact
are feeling very
sad about this decision because so much
good work has been put into keeping the
schools
opened and opening them up to begin with
let's start there opening the schools
when almost no other major school system
in america open
making them so safe but we set a very
clear standard
and we need to stick to that standard
and i want to emphasize to parents to
educators to staff to kids
that we intend to come back and come
back as quickly as possible
we are working right now with the state
of new york and that was a lot of what
we talked about this morning i had a
number of conversations with the
governor and our teams have been talking
throughout the morning
on exactly what it would take to come
back and bring our schools back quickly
and it will be a higher standard i want
that to be clear we have a stringent
health and
safety standard right now we're going to
have to raise that up even higher
three percent positivity in the whole
city
this means that the schools have to shut
down why why should the schools shut
down because the magical
3.0 percent threshold has been crossed
well because like 10 pm curfews and 10
person limits at thanksgiving
and six feet between people the number
was chosen arbitrarily
and after being chosen arbitrarily it
became gospel
as if there was ever something solid
behind it in this case specifically
behind the three percent number is a
deal that was struck with the teachers
unit
a deal it would seem was chosen
um because new york was certain to hit
it
it's like they wanted to choose a
threshold that they would
hit so that the schools could be shut
down again
we've learned during the pandemic what
we already knew that teachers unions
hate nothing so much as educating
children
they are enemies of education enemies of
children
and their goal is to make things as hard
as possible
on on on children especially this is why
teachers unions
should be forcibly abolished and
outlawed in my view but that's a
discussion for
another time now you may wonder what's
the positivity rate in new york for
schools
i mean who cares about positivity in the
whole city what about schools
are kids getting sick left and right in
school
is that why they shut it down well no a
new york times article
has the school positivity rate at get
this
.17 percent not 1.7
0.17 the highest estimate i've read is
0.23 percent
so take whichever you like split the
difference whatever it is the point is
it's very very low and if a fraction of
a percent of positivity for covid can
shut down the schools
then why is any school anywhere ever
open during flu season
flu is we all know this now more
dangerous for children
and i'm willing to bet that plenty of
schools match or exceed the
0.23 percent uh during flu season for
for uh
the infection right so so this is this
is just nonsense
but don't expect any decision maker in
charge to make any sense of the nonsense
governor cuomo was pressed
on school closures during a press
conference and um here's what he had to
say about it he didn't really want to
talk about it but this is what we got
out of him
what are you talking about how what are
you talking about
you're now going to override we did it
already
that's the law an orange zone in a red
zone
follow the facts still confused well
then you're confused
i'm confused parents are still confused
as well
they're schools they're not confused
you're confused
confused as well read the law and you
won't be confused
he's an absolute clown worst of all he's
an obnoxious clown which i suppose
all clowns are by definition there is no
science behind this there's no good
reason to do it
and yet it's being done that is the
theme
of the last many months no reason to do
it but we're gonna do it anyway
so taking a step back and widening the
lens uh what we see
is that american society in effect has
given up
on educating children it got scared of a
virus
and gave up on education it is one of
the most shameful and cowardly things
i have ever seen
now as i've argued before if this pushes
families towards homeschooling that will
ultimately be a net positive
for the kids and for society in general
but most kids are not being homeschooled
and uh in fairness not all families can
homeschool
there are many families who think they
can't but actually can if they
prioritize around it but
that doesn't mean that every family can
so for millions of children they in
effect
have not had an education since like
last april
there are millions of kids who right now
are not in school
and haven't been in school since the
middle of the spring and sitting there
looking at a computer for a few hours a
day that doesn't count as being in
school
and this deprivation the name of keeping
you know ourselves safe that's the thing
this is this is keeping ourselves safe
not our children
who aren't at much risk from coronavirus
this is about keeping us safe
we've shut down education and stopped
educating kids because we're scared
that we will get sick
it is as i said an act of collective
cowardice possibly
unmatched in american history and i
don't even think that's hyperbole
consider the psychological impact this
must be having on children
i mean not just the psychological impact
of not receiving a real education but
also of seeing
as a child that education is not a
serious
priority of those tasked with providing
it to you
see i can remember when i was in school
i always felt like it was extremely
important to all the adults around me
that i go to school and learn i always
it always seemed like that to me
no matter what you know they would send
us to school
and if they did shut us down for snow or
for some other reason
uh we had to make up that time later
i always felt like the school treated
school as an utterly crucial thing
i wasn't happy about this i should add
at the time as a kid um i would have
much preferred having teachers who moved
to the forest and canceled class i would
have loved that
i would have loved remote learning too
that's how this is how i know remo
remote learning is a bad idea it's
because when i was a kid i would have
loved it
but i would have loved it for all the
wrong reasons
so a lot of kids today um they may not
be
right now upset that the schools don't
care about school
but this is enormously harmful in the
long run
and we as the adults are supposed to be
the ones with the foresight to see that
now i say all this but i don't want to
give the impression that the school
system was doing you know
a good job of educating children before
all this
it wasn't and frankly a great many of
the kids
just went from not learning in person to
not learning remotely and in those cases
not much change really but
what we're seeing now are these school
systems not even trying
to teach the kids they're not even
pretending that education is a priority
education has been officially deemed
across the nation
non-essential and the people who deemed
it such
always felt that way about it now
they're letting the mask
slip a little bit at least that mask the
other mask the cloth the cloth mask is
still firmly
affixed to their faces so let's keep
this in mind going forward
because eventually the schools will be
open again someday
but we now know for certain how the
people who run the schools
really feel about it and how much they
really care about education
which is not at all and we should never
forget that let's get to uh our five
headlines
[Music]
okay let me read this to you from the
new york times it says researchers in
denmark reported on wednesday that
surgical masks
did not protect the wearers against
infection with the chronovirus in a
large randomized clinical trial
the study was published in the annals of
internal medicine
did not contradict growing evidence that
masks can prevent transmission of the
virus from wearer to others but the
conclusion is at odds with the view
that masks also protect the wearers a
position endorsed just last week by the
cdc
uh critics were quick to note the
study's limitations among them that the
findings depended heavily on
participants
reporting their own test results and
behavior at a time when both mask
wearing and infection were rare in
denmark
um then it goes on and says here's how
the study was conducted
from early april to early june
researchers at the university of
copenhagen
recruited about 6 000 participants who
had been tested beforehand to be sure
that they were not infected with chronic
virus
half were given surgical masks and told
to wear them when leaving their homes
the others were told not to wear masks
in public
at that time two percent of the danish
population was infected a rate lower
than
in many places in the u.s in europe
today
social distancing and frequent hand
washing were common but masks were not
about 4860 participants completed the
study
the researchers had hoped that the masks
would cut the infection rate by half
among wearers instead 42 people in the
mask
group or 1.8 percent got infected
compared with 53 in the unmask group or
2.1 percent
the difference was not statistically
significant dr henan
uh bungard lead author of the study
said our study gives indication of how
much you gain from wearing a mask
he concludes not a lot
so i mean this is science here this is
this is
probably from for as far as i'm aware
this is the most extensive study of its
kind
that's been done on mask usage as it
relates specifically
to the coronavirus um so this is some of
the best science we're going to find
yeah
no study is perfect and so you can you
could poke holes in it
so to speak um but
this is this is evidence in the column
that wearing a mask
isn't going to help you that much
now you could say well you should still
wear it from other people but now you
have to ask the question so if if
let's say if masks aren't doing anything
for you
and the thing is as much as we say oh
you know you're wearing the mask for
others
that's not really why people are wearing
it though i don't
i don't think that's really
psychologically i don't think that's why
people are wearing i think people are
wearing it
because it makes them feel safe yeah
they might also be concerned about
others but
they're the real reason people are
wearing it is because it makes them feel
safe
especially when you see someone wearing
a mask walking down the street
or in their car by themselves who are
they
who are they trying to protect no
they're doing it because it makes them
feel safe
and there's good evidence now that that
is a false sense of security
which is which is um which is bad
because it's
it's it's it's false but also it's it's
dangerous
i would think you don't want to give
people a false sense of security
you want them to have a um you know you
want them to have a reasonable idea an
accurate idea
of how much risk there really is for
them
um but now you have to ask okay so if
the mask
let's say the mask doesn't protect you
at all or hardly at all
not a lot as the author of the study
says so then let's say
matt's not going to protect you uh and
let's say you're a
you know a a younger healthy person
you're not symptomatic
you don't have chronovirus as far as you
know you have no symptoms at all
and you're going out in public and okay
you're social distancing
and if you have to cough you cough into
your sleeve i mean like
since why can't people do that anymore
why is that enough why do you need the
mask
if you're following those protocols
social distancing if you have to cough
you cough into your sleeve
you're not symptomatic
what's the point of the mask then in
that case what purpose is it really
serving that's the question
um okay now for a little bit of sanity
here's
governor gnome of south dakota as so
many other governors are going into
lockdown
shutting down schools mass mandates so
on and so forth here she
is giving her philosophy um
of how she's handling it going forward
and how she has handled it up to now
this is what she has to say i don't want
to approach a policy
or a mandate just looking to make people
feel good i want to do good and actually
put
forward provisions that make a
difference for families and these local
communities have some flexibility today
that sioux falls can make a different
decision than rapid city rapid city can
make a different decision than lemon
south dakota watertown can make a
different decision
than peer and and that's what some of
these local leaders are doing
in in reacting to the people in the
community based on what they want
she says i don't want a policy just to
make people feel good
sounds good to me that's a that's that's
exactly the right attitude and then she
and then she clarifies that
she's not stopping local
towns from having their own ordinances
if a local town
city wants to have its own policy they
can do that
she's not going to impose something on
everyone that to me
seems like the reasonable and correct
approach here
uh so governor noam continues to acquit
herself well
during this uh during this crisis number
three in case you were wondering if the
media would ever
you know be able to embarrass itself any
more than it already has
can it be more embarrassing than it's
already been well here's your answer
this is a headline in the daily mail
here's the headline this is real
it says ivanka trump blamed a fart on
her classmates when she was a bratty
teenager
and creepy donald commented on her
friend's weight according to a former
best friend
so this is lisandra ostrom who was
friends with ivanka trump back in their
youth she says that ivanka was nice and
charming you know a nice girl
baca never did anything to her really
except the fart perhaps
and yet ostrom has decided to stab her
old friend in the back in broad daylight
and she wrote this expose this blog post
or whatever it is
listing all of the terrible things that
ivanka did the only problem is
they're all pretty much along the lines
of farting in class
so here's more from the article it says
um
goes on for a while and then it says
ivanka also allegedly said
since when can a teacher afford a bmw
and quote
why is a police officer living in a
house like that while the pair were
watching movies
claiming they would not be able to
afford them in real life
lissandra says that ivanka also coaxed
other girls into bad behavior
including flashing their breasts at the
quote hot dog man from the windows of
their school
then talked her way out of trouble when
they were caught and then she says one
of the earliest memories i have of
ivanka from before we were friends is
when she blamed a fart on a classmate
then there's other stuff here too that
also sounds basically just made up
um lysandra also said that ivanka told
her that she quote
hated a necklace she wore with her name
in arabic and once said to her
how does your jewish boyfriend feel when
you're having sex and that necklace hits
him in the face
how can you wear that thing it just
screams terrorist
so that sounds made up to me but later
on in the article she acknowledges that
ivanka
is uh was generous has been generous to
her
they've maintained a cordial
relationship until now
and this is how she repays the
generosity
similar to uh melania trump's friend who
was
secretly recording her for you know
months on end and then released the
recordings
to the uh to the media but it once again
we have this effect
so we've seen now close confidants
of melania trump donald trump
uh and and now ivanka trump come
forward like spilling the beans
and none of them have anything it's
actually shocking how clean the trumps
actually are apparently
i would have assumed just based on the
fact i i i would assume about pretty
much any politician
that if their closest confidants and
friends old friends
come forward and and tell everything
they've ever
known about the person you know spilling
all of the beans i would assume that
there would be some
juicy tidbits in there about pretty much
any politician
or almost any person forget about
politician
but um that's not been the case with the
trumps
these they've been stabbed in the back
by people closest to them including
including secret recordings there isn't
one here as far as we know
maybe eventually there will be a secret
recording that comes out of the of the
uh
of the fart who knows but with
with melania and and donald trump secret
recordings
nothing much on them pretty surprising
but listen uh you might want to consider
that if there's someone that you've been
friends with
since childhood and they've always been
generous to you
and they were nice and charming and
you've had a cordial relationship
and then you're going to the media to
try to destroy them
even if all you have is a fart in fourth
grade or whatever
you might want to consider that you're
the bad guy just a thought
number four bbc has a report here about
how working from home
can make you racist and this really
shouldn't be a revelation
because everything makes you racist of
course if there's a thing in existence
that hasn't yet been accused of being
racist
or causing racism it's only because they
haven't gotten around to it yet
they're just sort of methodically going
through and covering
every single thing in existence so it'll
take them time to hit everything
so eventually we'll get reports like why
europa
is the most racist moon of jupiter and i
don't know something like
why eating omelets turns you into a
white supremacist
we'll get to all of that but for now
there's this uh it says
widespread working from home could lead
to an increase in racism and prejudice a
new report
warns workplace friendships are key to
breaking down misconceptions
according to the england and wales study
from the wolf institute
institute founder ed kessler said as
more people work from home they risk
going back into isolated silos he called
on ministers to focus on offices and
workplaces as a vital area for improving
community relations
um let's see it says the study suggests
that
of those who work in shared offices
three quarters 76
regardless of ethnicity we're in a
setting that is ethnically diverse
however it suggests that unemployed
people are 37 more likely
to only have friends from their own
ethnic group
and it warns that without alternative
settings to offices being set up
opportunities for social mixing between
different religious and ethic groups
will be greatly reduced well there's an
obvious solution here
affirmative action for the home
every home should be required to have at
least one
non-white person in it
of course it's also racist now you think
okay if that's the requirement
then there's an obvious way to make that
happen but no
that we've also learned it's racist for
a white person to adopt a non-white
person we learned that about amy coney
barrett of course
it became racist with her when because
of her
so we're gonna have to figure out some
other way around this maybe
white families could pay a non-white
person to stay in their home
kind of like renting a room out like
airbnb except the homeowner is now
paying for the privilege of someone
staying in their house
just to keep the racism in check this
could be a whole industry i've just come
up with here this could work
who's that woman who uh white white
people pay her to come to dinner
so that she can scream at them and call
them racist who's that woman that does
that
this this is and that's you know that
that that's working out well for her
very profitable
so maybe this could be a another
business she starts but really
this just shows you this this course
shows you uh how the left feels about
family
there's a reason that blm wants to
destroy the nuclear family by its own
emission
because they're they are suspicious of
families
they see people behind closed doors with
their own
family groups the left feels
uncomfortable with that because they
have no control
over it and they don't want people in
their own families coming up with their
own ideas
forming their own value systems it's
very very suspicious of that
um all right number five finally in
in more creepy japanese robot news
yesterday we had the
severed robotic hand that japanese dudes
are walking around holding
because it feels like a girlfriend we
had that yesterday uh it feels like a
girlfriend if you happen to be dating
the terminator now we have robovi
and you can see him here he's a robot
who goes around
and i guess stores in some stores in
japan have this this robot
and he goes around telling you to
socially distance and wear your masks
he's just reminding you
and if you don't comply it will
immediately incinerate you
actually no it just whines it whines at
you if you don't comply
i continue to be disappointed by the
robot technology um
in existence right now like we're in the
middle of this
actual real-life dystopia with
governments shutting down society
and now they're using robots but the
robots don't shoot lasers at you or
anything
they just annoy the hell out of you
that's what we get from
from robots but hey it's a step in the
right direction
finally we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation just a second but before we
do
you know as we've been talking about the
legacy media we're all
sort of disgusted and and sick of the
legacy media especially
not just during the election but through
trump's through four years of trump
we've seen
uh what they do and how little we can
trust them
and that's why you got to start looking
for alternatives to the legacy media
you know it's it's we can complain about
the mainstream media all day long but if
we keep
going to them for news and information
our complaints mean nothing
so i would say consider trading in your
cable and your new subscriptions with
the daily wire we have big plans for the
next four years and it starts today
candace owens joining the daily wire we
announced that recently uh very excited
about that she'll be launching a brand
new show with us early next year
we're also launching a whole bunch of
other stuff entertainment channel a new
investigative journalism team
building partnerships with like-minded
content creators like prageru
uh his whose entire show library will be
available on the site by the end of the
year
and we're going after the legacy media
and we're going to do it by building a
huge membership base of supporters like
you but of course we need your help for
that right now
just to show you we're serious we're
giving 25 off all memberships with code
election
over at dailywire.com subscribe
tomorrow is the last day that you can
get this deal so you gotta sign up now
don't uh don't waste your time members
get our articles ad free access to all
of our live broadcasts the full three
hours of the ben shapiro show
exclusive readers past content on the
website a lot of great stuff there
you'll miss out on if you're not a
member
and if you're considering an all-access
membership you can also join us for all
access live every night
live stream discussions with uh with our
hosts and our amazing online community
you also get not one but two of the
leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership as well as early and
sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wired products bunch
of stuff so remember that's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe you only have one more day to
take advantage of this replace the
legacy media
with the daily wire you won't regret it
now time for our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we need
to have a very important conversation
about
hallway etiquette now that i'm working
here in the office i expect that this is
an issue that will arise frequently as
it does
in any workplace so i'm issuing a
pre-emptive cancellation
of everyone who violates the rules of
hallway adequate etiquette everyone here
at dailywire understands
that if they are canceled by me or
violate one of my rules
they must immediately resign this i'm
pretty sure is written
in the employee handbook at least it's
written in mine because i added it
in crayon now as everyone knows passing
by another human being in a hallway
is a daunting challenge the problem is
that as you both
approach each other you must time your
greeting for exactly the right moment
or else immense awkwardness ensues
if you're still 20 paces apart and you
say hello at that point then you have to
walk the remaining steps having already
issued your greeting
you can't very well greet each other and
then have 15 seconds of silence as you
complete your walk past one another
it would be akin to you know making
brief small talk on an elevator
and then saying bye to the person when
you both still have
10 floors left to climb so you say all
right well good talking to you see you
later
then you're both just standing there for
another 30 seconds we're talking nuclear
levels of awkwardness
what this means that is that if you fire
your greeting round too early in the
walk past somebody in the hallway
when you're both still say 15 seconds
apart you must then have precisely 15
seconds of small talk
to fill the gap but if the small talk
goes on too long
or if one of you says something that
requires a longer answer
now you'll end up stopping and having a
stop in chat which is exactly what you
both want to avoid
that's what's what's at stake here if
you get it wrong
you may be stuck having god forbid a
full-on conversation and nobody wants
that
the key then is to wait to acknowledge
the other person until you are exactly
four paces apart in order to achieve
this you must
make sure to avoid eye contact until
precisely the moment
when you hit the four pace threshold you
can accomplish this by looking down at
your phone looking up at the ceiling
staring straight ahead noticing a smudge
on your shoe i have a tendency of
noticing lint on my sleeve
whenever i'm in a hallway with someone
i'll brush at the lint
until we hit four paces and then i look
up and i say oh hey how are you to which
they can respond great how are you and i
can say
great great then i go back to the lint
for about half a beat to sell the ruse
boom four paces have been completed and
i have succeeded in passing by the
person without having a meaningful or
extended interaction
which again is the whole objective now
on occasion you may run into someone who
throws this plan for a loop because
when you say hey how are you they
actually have the audacity to answer the
question honestly
actually telling you how they are as if
you wanted to know
thereby sucking you into a vortex of
conversation that may take minutes
to extricate yourself from not much you
can do about so
you know psychopaths like this except
avoid them at all costs one additional
tip
if you really want to avoid talking to
people in hallways or making eye contact
one thing you could try doing is walking
backwards through the hallway
this will have the added benefit of not
only avoiding eye contact and
conversation in hallways but probably in
general too because your co-workers will
think you're a weird freak
of course this can backfire if the other
person is also walking backwards
so you might try somersaulting through
the hallways that's something the other
person has to jump over you but again it
avoids conversation with co-workers
especially after you get fired one other
wrinkle to explore here briefly
what happens when you're out say at the
grocery store and you pass by an
acquaintance
in like the condiment aisle well you
follow the four pace rules as discussed
simple enough but many of us have been
in the crisis situation
where you pass by the same person again
in the pasta aisle
you can't use the hey how are you line
because it's already been asked and
answered
now you have to make a brief joke about
the fact that you already saw them maybe
something like
long time no see or something similar if
you pass by them a third time
you could probably get away with a hey
stop stalking me
but there cannot be a fourth time under
no circumstance can you allow yourself
to pass the person a fourth time
if you end up in the same aisle as them
a fourth time you have no choice but to
drop your groceries
run in the other direction change your
name move to mexico
these are the rules of passing people in
hallways or aisles
it's very complicated but they must be
strictly observed
all who fail in such observances are of
course
canceled that's going to do it for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
white house press secretary kelly
mcinenneny describes coronavirus rules
as
orwellian a danish study shows that
masks don't protect wearers from the
virus
duh and a major left-wing youtube
channel
asks just what white people happen to be
superior at check it out at the michael
knowles show